[Music]
all right roundtable reviews a little
R&R with the Lord's the inaugural fresh
out of Avengers in game spoiler cast a
warning off the top spoiler cast man we
just came out of the Avengers what are
we thinking right now saw we just saw
one of the conclusions to an epic saga
where we act Wow it's hard it's hard to
really put into words I thought the
movie started out a little bit it's a
little slow I was a little worried at
first but when everything started to
come together honestly the the oh ish
moments for my man particularly I have
to say who is your man sir Captain
America fan so both of those characters
I thought had fitting endings just
honestly honestly what they were what
they managed to do in this movie with 10
years worth of movies to have to sort of
round out and close off I think they did
an amazing job obviously nothing is
perfect right but honestly I don't
really it's so satisfying you rarely
find that in something this huge which
you don't find anything this huge you
know 22 movies in trying to tie out all
these storylines lot of storylines I
thought the ending was so great so
satisfying
you know we laughed we cried some
tearjerkers teacher Kajal woo yeah katsu
let's bring it to you sir you've been
following this series for a long time
you know I know me you got a motion I
heard some emotion from both of our
chairs so what do you feel
[Laughter]
Twitter and Facebook they were talking
about like they're getting choked up and
stuff like that it's like like okay I
mean I do get sensitive with that but I
was like I couldn't see it getting there
that way but then when it happened just
any any part in particular what part got
you the most I think the part when it
looked like that
it looked like they were they were at
that last end with a nose then with a
nose and then just out of no way
everyone that they brought back just
came in one felt a big everybody showed
up yeah I'm not really big on its
emotional moments it's corny moment
about anything else like when you when
you talk about and trying to wrap that
up when you when you have moments in
that final movie have to sort of sum all
of that up you have to make sure you got
to a point where you earned every single
one of those whether it be laughter
whether it be sadness whether whatever
may be and they earned all right listen
um movies like this these are
culmination of over what eight ten years
of MCU right and let's let's let's call
it what it's like for them to do all
these storylines
I'm absolutely amazing I have to say
that now remember I'm very hard on this
because I'm an Infinity Gauntlet guy I'm
a cosmic guy and is everything gonna be
like the comics no I know that but I
guess my only issue in the beginning
song is a crime I didn't like the quick
Thanos kill like it pissed me off
I felt I felt like he does
served better as far as a character and
yeah yes so it's for the character so I
just felt like he would be too smart for
him to just be in the same spot and I
realized what's going on I just feel
like that part I struggled with I'll be
honest right so as the movie got on it
took me a while to get over that so I'm
gonna be honest like I didn't like how
fast they found him what happens well
there's so many characters that are gone
what happened the reality is Neverland
was supposed to get it right and then
never right and then what was supposed
to happen is she wasn't gonna assimilate
to her godhood when you first get it
they went from that I'm fine with that I
guess like I said them killing him in
the future I mean in the regular time I
struggle with that right once I got out
of my emotions with that I'll be honest
at that points for me I did not like
that at all but as it went on you know I
mean I knew it at the time I'm feeling
like they were gonna go back cool with
that
you know the payoff the emotional
payoffs have seen future your past self
and all that very cool like that aspect
you know I'm saying and then the gems
and all that stuff and then as it went
on my ranking started to get high you
start to get those emotional payoff you
start to see what was going on final
battle Oh amazing absolutely amazing
those characters shine in their own
rights with callbacks to specific things
that happen in their movies and and just
little moments that if you've been
watching all along as a fan and somebody
who's been there from the beginning you
can just you see those little things and
you're like that's for me that's for me
like you know that I think this movie
and and apart from again I haven't read
comic books for a long time so I don't
have that attachment to those storylines
I think what they've done with this as
its own thing as its own universe per se
I think let me ask you this question so
you were okay with the tailless thing
with them again I didn't know I don't
know the history of it history
the whole thing with the 1001 thing is I
knew that they killed him if they kill
him early there was gonna be added one
or two things one either Dennis was
gonna come back with a vengeance which
he did toward the end and that was like
a full hour I was actually impressed the
way that they actually brought the way
that they brought Dennis back was
actually good for the story and it
actually made a lot of sense okay so I
was either thinking that they were
either gonna do that or they were gonna
bring back they were gonna bring like
another major villain oh thank you
because you know they had the rumors of
somebody room was going on there was so
many things going on okay all right so
I'm sorry I'll cut you before that
didn't necessarily bother me just
because I didn't have that context for
it I thought it was again a fitting
moment because door was so angry at
himself for failing that initial time
that it was like whoa this is my chance
and we can't do anything about it he's
already let us know the stones have gone
right so I'm gonna get this satisfaction
of killing him and so I understood the
emotions behind and again in the context
of this universe and movies that moment
made sense of listen I'm hard on these
things man you know they I guess you
know the five years later think they you
know they fooled me I didn't know where
they were gonna go right so that good
the five year thing later cool drunk out
of shape daughter
I'm not struggle with that apart from
movies that came before the MCU to see
some changes which obviously Wonder
Woman Shazam they're not taking
themselves as seriously and I think the
ability to ground these superheroes hope
was little right and have them be
affected by by human emotions and human
problems makes sense to me so the fact
that he would get fat
and depressed it makes sense to me it
makes sense to me and I can laugh and
again it's a perfect way to add that
balance it's not taking yourself super
seriously all the time and you have
those moments of levity I thought it
worked
I was yeah bye bro he lost absolutely
lost he lost a lot from Asgard then he
went to everything with yeah sacrifice
was brutal the Ironman hit me you know I
didn't predict that I thought it would
be capped in his own way you know I knew
Iron Man Tony Stark could not handle the
gauntlet combined you know they had that
physiology you know we knew him using it
I the sacrifice would be great you know
so dad that was a high moment from an
emotional standpoint I thought they hit
all the notes with that you know him I
even on the battlefield the reuniting of
the characters that actually touched me
you know I just to see people
interacting that have been snapped the
verses the non snap that was crazy I
thought he was the perfect person to
make the ultimate sacrifice because he
was the first and he was the one that
his whole mo from the beginning was
selfish selfish you had to be turned
into yes a superhero he had to accept
that role and I thought it was fitting
that he was Wonder did it and the one
who's always been that way got his happy
ending the one who would have literally
thrown himself on the grenade
got his happy ending I thought it was
perfect my favorite characters going up
were Batman
Captain America Iron Man in that order
absolutely and to see those two guys
those characters
hi can you run I don't never see it
again that's why I hit me too because of
the emotional connection with Tony Stark
at him starting the MCU let's be honest
you know if it wasn't for Ironman one
you know it is what it is what about you
like what abou cog did you feel about
that scene did you did he hit you but
again it goes back to what I said about
swimming stark right I think Natasha is
a character that came originally from
she was just like clean she's an
assassin she was she was paid to kill
people she had she was the term she had
she has a lot of red in her ledger yeah
I think at the end she still felt she
had to pay for that and the character
she had become by the end was that hero
willing to take make that sacrifice so I
think at that same time it's that we
actually within remember when they had
the round table with the Holograms and
whatnot
you actually saw how everything was
taking a toll on the Tasha now she had
lost everything the family that she had
made the new gold that she had done once
she go once she became an Avenger like
she lost all of that and she was still
trying to struggle to hold on my big
issue with it is that first
Clint's why I bother pulling Ronan and
they really didn't put that much in it I
mean the whole thing that because he
lost his family he became Ronin and it
really didn't add anything to his
character in this movie anything is like
okay he was going around yeah right once
he came back he still felt like Clint
yeah pretty much yeah I agree I agree I
agree he wasn't a different character
per se he was just okay Danny's back in
the fall with the Avengers now he's not
killing people just the sake of
murdering like the whole Ronan was
wasted and then when it got to the whole
soulstone part it's like we
we have that emotional investment with
that I did like I said I feel that she
had taken that journey and she
sacrificed herself for the only family
she knew which is all of the Avengers
and by that at that point she had taken
sort of a very leadership type role in
sort of policing what was left of the
world so for me I dig doubt that's
another character who grew into this
position right of leadership where you
know taking the fall is something that
that person would do and I think again
for the family that she had you know a
surrogate family right I think if it
worked
god I waited Cara hi Buffy I'm caught in
the middle I understand where you're
going with it you know listen we knew we
were gonna lose characters again I was
completely surprised I did not think we
would lose those leaves her and then I
didn't see how we're gonna do the cap I
think we can lose ball for them in the
way we lost ball for them you know I'm
saying sort of cap ding I get it you
know I'm saying because I knew when he
went back in the past he started to see
you know where he's staying at that
window family there he was you had them
feelings he was gonna put the ring on it
you know saying but oh no you said now I
get the elephant in the room real quick
for wrap up is um a lot of people had
controversies with Captain Marvel right
coming in they were very worried you
know sir but I faith in fire in the fire
that he would not she would not come in
near the movie would start she would
slap Thanos in a movie be over like I
knew that was the reality is I fell she
had just about she surprised but it was
perfect because be about her didn't need
to be
at all she needed to be the boost
absolutely absolutely no they will rap
soon okay
[ __ ] yes and it's gonna be and I'm
gonna point to another moment as well
then I thought I love the moment where
all the women got together I loved it I
just felt like it was forced yeah a
little bit a little little second year I
don't think I really wish I had been
Bucky just because honestly even I do
know about absolutely we know that
they're playing it yeah right and for me
I know Sam was there with him yeah I
know so you don't feel it was deserved
necessarily I think between the both of
them because [ __ ] he's been with him
from the very beginning what they've
been through and again Bucky is a
character that needed to grow into
deserving that yes absolutely right on
your I just I don't know something about
I you know what it is this is where I'm
going to the comics and say I always
felt that lucky was a better fit for cap
okay then Falcon I was like Falcon has
his own character I for me so you know
to me that bothered me a little the
woman's part it was great it was great
they all came together it just I wish it
happened more organic I got the war was
crazy though I did love the war I mean
it was epic
you know Thanos is on me versus you know
the heroes coming at the right moment
that was cool I like the going in the
past action I want to comment with the
Doctor Strange with oh we got the
callback to the sorceress the sorcerer
supreme you didn't say it now is dope um
just real quick cuz I know we got to
wrap up soon eh they cleaned up around
us but um the real soon what I was gonna
say is you know we had our rankings
coming in you know as far as our MCU and
now we've all seen them game so I'll
give it the card first
now what's your ranking now seeing ink
does it crack the the holy five your top
five
what I told you why I had guardians of
the galaxy so high I had Guardian to
galaxy guardians of the galaxy over
Avengers mainly because the movie itself
was an adventure right that you saw that
they had something to do
they went from place to place there was
an actual storyline to go to go into the
Avenger slander early now continue no
waiting on duties Avengers Wesley that's
rich but it just wasn't just okay
guardians galaxy over Avengers things it
felt like a full Avengers kinda like
Star Wars where they had to do something
they had to go first they had to suffer
the end suffer the loss that they came
after they kill thanos they couldn't
bring the people back then they went
into the time highs and then they went
into to bring everybody back and then
the whole insane where you rank this er
number okay number three soft pre
ranking post ranking anything change
this is my top five number four and
finding war okay I would say maybe I
have to really really think about it but
I think endgame might crack that number
five like crack file because it brings
together everything it closes the loops
and but the end game on its own without
in the context of the entire ten years
in front of it right you don't it
doesn't have that same resonance so it
needs these other movies for it to be as
powerful as it is got you I think so
that's why I still think like Winter
Soldier works on its own I still think
these other movies work on even infinity
war on its own its own because if you if
they had said boom that's it oh great is
taking a villa win yeah it's like The
Sopranos ending right like don't stop
acts music cut that's is so on its own
even that is super powerful so I think
endgame needs all these other movies to
sort of make it be as powerful as it is
okay Mike cracky just because of the
epicness of it mmm but it's right there
it's right there for me this is tough so
pre
free coming in I had on part one it was
I had a what you call as far as a
standalone I had Winter Soldier black
panther
I had infinity war third and I still
have my Avengers one and I have got I
was at a galaxy round in and out um you
know someone mentioned I didn't have
anything after seeing this I'll be
honest I don't know if it cracks my five
I'm not saying it's not great it's good
it's it's fantastic again it wraps up
the storyline but I agree with you saw
infinity war you grab that we go you
grab him drink to school so on infinity
war though like you said so I've had so
much of an emotional way because it's
something that MCU never did before the
villain one you left the theater feeling
away you know I'm saying and I'm not
taking anything away this was fantastic
and hard to do all these all these years
of MCU films to culminate to this moment
and it was a good I'm not gonna say it
wasn't it I probably won't even have to
rewatch again but for right now it's
it's on the fringe it's not in it yet on
the cause of if we just compare
masterpieces at certain level you know
Sam but I will I have to have to
subtract points for that that's the
thing is they wanted you to think that
all off the table that's what they and I
would have been crazy they have really
been the case right but I think I think
what cog is referring to is the fact
that they killed present Thanos to had
like he had all those emotions already
he knew what it felt to give up Gamora
right this Thanos didn't know that yet
so he was being fed that information
from the sidelines so he interpreted it
and and responded accordingly but the
emotional resonance wasn't the same
because he didn't go through it per se
right right so it would have been
interesting to see if the nanos who had
gone through it on actually done all
those things I had to deal with that
emotional weight reacted to the Avengers
coming back
agree thing the whole thing with it is
that they knows one in part one he
doesn't know why I get it I get it I
just because of his intelligence in the
manipulation of every storm for the
combination of all these Marvel films
you can't tell me that he's just gonna
make this mistake and just snap on a
planet and then they go find where he
had and they were gonna get him and then
it's gonna be mad easy you think oh you
think is he don't care actually we are
going with that he wasn't his whole
purpose for doing it was not selfish
facts the complexity of the character a
selfish thing and it was even less
selfish to risk killing himself to get
rid of the stones to make sure nobody
could ever do it again
exactly well look they clean up around
us so we wanted to wrap this thing up
but you're out table reviews with the
Lords the first one cinema R&R with the
Lords quarter shot the king you're in
luck episode 1 yo give us feedback we
just got a new series we're trying to do
you know lo spoiler class-action so you
already know catch the iron Lords every
Sunday 1:00 p.m. Eastern noir King the
king of statues he's out there and of
course the last word woody bond says we
got a lot of content coming please check
us out Lords of gaming dotnet the
website you want p.m. everybody enjoy
your night roundtable reviews
[Music]